I've just written out these lines of how
1 plus X expansion again just because I
want to introduce some new notation that
will make it easier to work with these
things as the numbers start to get
larger and also help us to be able to
use our calculators when the time is
right okay now see these coefficients
right as you've noticed they are very
predictable okay they come out of here
not only are they predictable there's a
there's an interesting pattern to them
okay such an interesting pattern that
I'm going to devote a whole set of new
notation to that path okay so you can
see up here and I'll add it in down for
the subsequent lines I have I've
highlighted the coefficients there's the
important parts you can see that
regardless of what the other bits inside
the binomial expansion are right once
you expand them the coefficients are
always going to be these numbers these
numbers are very important okay so I
mean getting introduced to kind of
parallel ways of writing down what these
coefficients are with relation to number
one what's his power okay and number two
which coefficient and am i interested in
okay so another way to say that is
because all these numbers are the same
as these numbers I'm going to write it
in terms of which row I'm in and which
number along in the road okay so here's
the notation this is what actually okay
this notation which you actually find on
your calculator I'm looking for it is on
mine it's above the multiplication and
division sites is this NCR another way
of writing it a faster way which I
encourage you to do I think it's better
but you need to be able to recognize
both is on the N and B are on top of
each other in a set of parentheses like
so okay it mean exactly the same thing I
read them is NCR or in choose R or in
combination are and the reason for those
waiting to become clear later okay what
does it mean
in these things here right if I were to
generalize that to say what if we raised
it through the power of n okay the
coefficients will change accordingly
with that okay
they'll give you a new road it'll be the
nth row of Pascal's triangle so NC R is
the coefficient like or actually it's
it's the particular coffee should be our
coefficient in the expansion of whatever
to the power of n okay it's the
coefficient of in sorry 1 plus X good so
if I can give these as some examples
okay let's go into this one let's go for
this one in here I rewrite this I'm
going to use I like this I think it's a
bit quicker and I have to write one this
letter I so that's the right identities
but anyway what kind of power do I have
here it's a 2 right so the first thing
I'm going to have is to see or choose or
whatever and the first term is zero okay
do you remember before why we said it's
a good idea to start with zero rather
than one is because really there's
actually an X to the power of zero
hiding in there we just start writing
okay cuz it index one so there's the
first term the next term will be I'm
still the power to the N hasn't changed
right but it's the next term along okay
that coefficient attaches to the X like
so okay and of course that means
following the pattern the last term
alone will be - in there - there you go
okay I can do the next one as well
what's changed it's just the the power
that's the end right so these are all
going to be three something 3 1 X 3 - x
squared you can see sorry I forgot the
exquisite the power here in this
particular expansion always matches this
on above okay plus 3/3
execute okay so we can use this it makes
a lot easier to write things especially
when these numbers become very large we
don't really care what they are so long
as we know what they signify okay